foreign
let's go to Dallas Texas man homeboy
called my bluff what's up Nathan how are
you today Dr deloni I'm good all right
so to set the stage here the last show
um
we reached out to your wife she wrote a
letter like an OG pin and paper letter
yeah
do what she said you love them
I love them
um but usually they're people send
letters like you know they're like real
happy or thank you so much or here's
here's how because of your show we've
I'm doing this now in my life and my
life's better
your wife's letter was like Hey I'm
dealing with this and I was like man we
gotta reach out to her well then halfway
through our conversation I'm like man I
really the person I need to be talking
to right now is your husband
and if he would call me that'd be
awesome and then here you are man oh
yeah kudos to you brother kudos to you
hey just so you know she talks really
good about you and you're not around it
doesn't happen a lot on the show man so
well done dude well way to be a husband
of Integrity who honors his wife man
that's cool all right so you in your
voice recap what's going on and how I
can help
through a letter so
um I do know you know she was talking
about my mom and the whole situation
with her with her leaving and the way
she left
uh kind of put a strain on you know mine
and her relationship not my wives but my
mother's and
oh man
is it almost exactly as I
thought it was going to play out so for
everybody
your mom
um met somebody on Twitter
right after 30 years of marriage 30 plus
years of marriage just surprises
everybody everybody thinks she went out
for a run and she moves away and then
she sends a message to your brother that
says I didn't just leave your dad I left
all of y'all this is over
right and then disappears
yeah
that's exactly how it played out it's a
it's a lot to unpack really it was what
three four or five years ago
see it's right before me and my wife got
married
yeah this is also a week before your
wedding or two two months actually good
gosh man
so
I'm in Dangerous Ground both of us are
from Texas we both know we don't talk
about each other's moms Fair
yet I gotta talk about your mom is that
cool that's that's fine all right
I'll be as respectful as I can
um
what your mom did was one of what I
would consider a core evil
do you agree with that or no
yeah I do agree
what part of you is still trying to hang
on and fix this relationship or make it
right
you know it's one of those deals the
heart the heart says one thing and head
says another
and it's real hard to
still cut ties because at the end of the
day that's still your mom but she was so
specific in how she cut ties with you
right
and you know it's one of those deals
it's like you want to come up with a
reason for why she did what she did
there's not one man maybe between her
and your dad but not you right right
and it's just one of those deals I guess
it's real hard to accept what she did
and you can't like I said you come up
with the reasons and it was well it was
better off for her to cut the ties to
make herself feel better
and you know it comes down to basically
selfishness it is is what it is yeah
and you you will never know ever the
dynamic behind closed doors of your mom
and your dad's relationship
that's like no one will ever know the
way he looked at it or what he said what
he whispered good bad awful no one will
ever know
yeah and that's what's so hard about it
is you know you saw the outer Dynamic
you know what they put on on display 33
years of marriage and then uh my dad
worked the night shift and for him to
come home in the morning and she's just
gone uh she left her ring on the table
uh all the jewelry that us kids and
grandkids that bought her she left it
and just open Life didn't tell anybody
didn't say anything to anybody the only
person she told was a sister and that's
how he found out she left
and it's just that at the trail I guess
yeah
and I would tell you that the success of
your future mirrors the success of your
future parenting and the success of your
future emotional
health
is contingent on you making peace with
that betrayal not trying to fix it
right because you can't
it's so unimaginable it's not
unimaginable for a wife to get fed up
and leave her husband that happens all
the time and right sometimes good for I
mean way to go right
but to take all the kids jewelry
and to just try to control alt delete
a couple of sons and a daughter
that's evil yeah that's the embodiment
of it
has she tried to Circle back and say I'm
sorry and how's my kid like how is she
making her way because your wife's
question was I don't want this woman in
my house and but I also wanna I wanna
love my husband and I know he's in a
weird spot is she trying to make her way
back in or are you trying to
Create A New Path
honestly I feel like I'm trying to
create a new path because I don't know
if my wife had told you our son was born
two weeks ago oh congratulations oh dude
and you've got this picture that's not
gonna happen
and you know Me growing up you know I
had my grandparents around but it wasn't
uh you know the uh Hallmark picture
perfect you know nothing ever is but you
know I had my grandparents around they
helped us out and you know the older I
get the more I look back and more my
memories are a word for them there
there's I feel like a lot of resentment
towards my grandparents and I don't want
that for my kid Nathan
there's you can't control that right
your mom cannot be around your kid
she can't
she's not a safe person of character who
I would put in the life of my child
for a number of reasons
but the hurt you felt and the pain you
felt
when two months before your marriage
your mom just evaporated in front of you
and sent a note saying
I'm leaving you too and here's all your
crap back that you've bought me over the
years
I'm not putting my my kid through that
or the chance that would happen now
if you know anything about me in this
show I'm always about Redemption always
if she comes back to you
on her knees saying I
committed a core core violation to the
soul of my children and I'm so sorry
and y'all wanted to start a multi-year
process of regaining trust and regaining
connection and communication still
before you ever see my kids
I'd support that
support that
but you were you're creating you're
setting up a recipe for disaster in your
home because your wife is looking at you
at the woman who destroyed her husband
and after you've picked yourself off the
ground bloody scraped up completely torn
into
your wife hands you your first son
and you're heading back to that same
dragon that got you the last time
right
you've got to grieve the loss of that
picture brother because it's gone she
left
and dude I hate it for you man
I hate it for you yeah
have you been anything other than angry
have you wept yet
um
honestly probably not I mean when she
first left you know uh us kids came
together real strong and then shortly
after we got married you know things
kind of fell apart and that was probably
the last time I had basically felt any
emotion around my family
yeah base I usually just you know it's
one of those deals you just kind of try
to suppress it and work through it no
you don't you don't just press it or do
it I I don't it's not depressive but I I
Channel it through my work okay you know
I'm a Hands-On guy so I just
you know I do my job and I work through
my process and you know I signed up for
better help you know you always talk
about that and I did better help good
and talk to my therapist and he helped
me through a lot of stuff good good
so
um
here's your homework assignment okay
and if you ever listen to this show
um
I I recommend this a lot but here's your
homework assignment it's going to be
unique to you
normally we do this when somebody's died
and in many ways
your mom did
right
the haunting part for you is
her ghost Still Remains and that just
It's haunting
because if you are any human being at
all
you're a son and you're asking yourself
what what was so unlovable about me
what's so great about this Twitter
account what's so bad about my your
grandson for God's sake there will not
be a rational answer to for this because
it's an irrational Act
and so I want you to write and even if
you're not a writer you got to do this
I want you to write your mom a letter
one of them is going to be how angry you
are
and I want you for the first time to
actually feel this stuff
you did this to us
I was your son
the second thing letter I want you to
write to your mom
is a letter about heartbreak
I'm sad
and I want that to be the start of the
letter dear Mom I'm really sad
I had this picture of what my life was
going to look like you were going to be
a part of it we're going to have a
different kind of relationship with
grandparents
you're going to be that crazy funnel
grandma that
whatever whatever
and you left me and I'm really sad
and the third letter you're going to
write your mom is dear Mom
so we're moving on
and I want you to let her know what
she's going to miss
and here's some things she's going to
miss she's going to miss how great of a
father her son's gonna be
and what a man a character and integrity
he's gonna be because he's never gonna
leave his kids or his wife
she's gonna miss t-ball games and she's
gonna miss when
your little one learns to walk and goes
and crashes into thing and the first ER
visit with the big gotta get stitches
and
gonna miss all that the recital and the
violin concert and the karate match or
whatever you can miss it all that stuff
and I want you to end that letter with I
wish you the best
and I hope your life has turned out how
you wanted it to and that's it and after
that we're setting the sucker down
and those will be three really tough
letters to write
yeah I mean they're already tough yeah
but yeah she doesn't she she not only
does she not get to see your kid I don't
think you fully metabolized she has told
you I don't ever want to see your kid
I don't ever want to see you
right you've got to take ownership of
that awful awful
gut-wrenching reality
it's the worst I I can't I'm sitting
here thinking
um
my son asked me this morning hey Doc you
dropped me off at work and he cleans out
the neighbor's horse stalls and spreads
manure with this tractor thing and he
does a bunch of odd jobs for a neighbor
on their horse ranch and I was like
absolutely man I'm leaving at this time
this morning
um be ready to go and he's like yes sir
and then I also walked into the shower
and um no I went down to work out and
then I got up and went up in the shower
and I got to thinking about a talk I've
got to do this afternoon
and I heard banging on my door
and I thought the kids are just causing
Havoc like they do in the morning and I
totally ignored it
and then I come out of my shower like
where is he
I was 20 minutes late
and he'd gone on sprinting down our
driveway that's about a quarter of a
mile
sprinting through the fields over the
creek
to get to work on time
and I was so ashamed I was sad that I'd
done that
and I drove my car over
to where he works and drove all the way
to the back pasture
and he saw me stop the tractor and he
came over and I weighed him over and I
hugged him
and I said hey man I told you I was
going to be there to give you a ride
and I absolutely failed you I'm sorry I
lied to you I told you I would and I
didn't I didn't show up it wasn't a
person of integrity and he's like it's
okay Dad I said No Man's not okay
why do I tell you that
Nate I'm not the best dad in the world
man I'm trying to figure this thing out
but to send my son a letter that says
I'm leaving you too
I can't compute that
because I Dishonored my son this morning
by giving my word on something and not
coming through and I can't hardly
breathe
and so I want you to own the full
magnitude is what is of what has
happened to you because what's happened
to you is a is one of the core wrongs a
mom looking at her son and her and her
daughter saying
I'm leaving y'all
and you can't avoid it you can't just
suppress it you can't just work it like
get down feelings get down get down you
can man
because they will resurface and they
will wreak havoc on your new marriage on
your on your parenting with your kids on
your relationship with your siblings and
on and on and on
so the only path forward is through the
storm my brother
I'm I can't tell you how proud of you I
am for for calling better help and
getting some counseling that's awesome
I want you to write these letters and in
some shape form or fashion commit to
your wife before I ever reach out to my
mom before I ever try to reconnect or at
some point she wants to reconnect
we will do this together because I'm
really emotional about it and I need
somebody who's going to give me some
perspective and insight that I may not
have when I get emotional and your wife
will say awesome
congrats on being a great husband and a
great dad my brother
and for everybody out there you have to
choose reality you got to own reality
here's what has happened in my life The
Good the Bad and the evil
and it's only from that starting line
can you then ask what are we going to do
now where do we go from here